الله اكبر الله اكبر
اكبر اشهد ان لا اله الا
الله اشهد ان محمدا رسول
الله حي على
الصلاه حي على
الفلاح قد قامت
الصلاه قد قامت
الصلاه الله اكبر الله اكبر اكبر لا اله
الا
الله استووا واعتدلوا ساووا الصفوف سدوا
الفرج
يتلا الله اكبر
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم
صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم
ولا
الضالين
امين قد افلح
المؤمنون الذين هم في صلاتهم
خاشعون والذين هم عن اللغو
معرضون والذين هم للزكاه
فاعلون والذين هم لفروجهم
حافظون الا على ازواجهم او ما ملكت
ايمانهم
فانهم غير
ملومين فمن ابتغى
وراء ذلك اولئك هم
العادون والذين هم لاماناتهم وعهدهم
راعون والذين هم على صلواتهم
يحافظون
اولئك هم
الوارثون الذين يرثون الفردوس هم فيها
خالدون ولقد خلقنا الانسان من سلاله من
طين ثم جعلناه نطفه في قرار
مكين ثم خلقنا النطفه علقه فخلقنا العلقه
مضغه فخلقنا المضغه
عظاما فكسونا العظام لحما ثم
انشاناه خلقا اخر فتبارك الله احسن
الخالقين ثم انكم بعد ذلك
لميتون ثم انكم يوم القيامه
تبعثون الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن حمده
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين ولقد خلقنا فوقكم سبع طرائق وما كنا
عن الخلق
غافلين
وانزلنا من السماء
ماء بقدر فاسكناه في الارض وانا على ذهاب
به
لقادرون فانشا لكم به جنات من نخيل
واعناب لكم فيها فواكه كثيره ومنها
تاكلون وشجره تخرج من طور سي ناء تنبت
بالدهن وصبغ
للاكلين وان لكم في الانعام
لعبره نسقيكم مما في بطونها ولكم فيها
منافع
كثيره ومنها
تاكلون وعليها وعلى الفلك
تحملون الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله
[Silence]
الله السلام عل
345 345
[Silence]
‏night جزاك الله
با
[Silence]
استووا الله
اكبر بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله رب
العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين
اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين ولقد ارسلنا نوحا الى قومه فقال يا
قوم اعبدوا الله ما لكم من اله غيره افلا
تتقون فقال الملا الذين كفروا من قومه ما
هذا الا بشر مثلكم يريد ان يتفضل عليكم
ولو شاء الله لانزل
ملائكه ما سمعنا بهذا في ابائنا
الاولين ان هو الا رجل به جنه فتربصوا به
حتى حين قال رب انصرني بما
كذبون فاوحينا اليه ان اصنع الفلك باعيننا
ووحينا فاذا جاء امرنا وفارت النور فاسلك
فيها من كل زوجين اثنين واهلك الا من سبق
عليه القول منهم ولا تخاطبني في الذين
ظلموا ان هم
مغرقون فاذا استويت انت ومن معك على الفلك
فقل الحمد لله الذي نجانا من القوم
الظالمين وقل رب انزل لي منزلا مباركا
وانت خير
المنزلين ان في ذلك لايات وان كنا لمبتلين
ثم انشانا من بعدهم قرنا
اخرين فارسلنا فيهم رسولا منهم ان اعبدوا
الله ما لكم من اله غيره افلا
تتقون وقال الملا من قومه الذين كفروا
وكذبوا بلقاء الاخره واترفناهم في الحياه
الدنيا ما هذا الا بشر
مثلكم ما هذا الا بشر مثلكم ياكل مما
تاكلون منه ويشرب مما
تشربون ولئن اطعتم بشرا مثلكم انكم اذا
لخاسرون ايعدكم انكم اذا متم وكنتم ترابا
وعظاما انكم
مخرجون هيها ت هيهات لما توعدون ان هي الا
حياتنا الدنيا نموت ونحيا وما نحن
بمبعوثين ان هو الا رجل افترى على الله
كذبا وما نحن له
بمؤمنين قال رب انصرني بما
كذبون قال عما قليل
ليصبحن
نادمين فاخذتهم الصيحه بالحق فجعلناهم
غثاء فبعدا للقوم
الظالمين ثم انشانا من بعدهم قرونا
اخرين ما تسبق من امه اجلها وما
يستاخرون ثم ارسلنا رسلنا تترى كلما جاء
امه رسولها ك ذبوه
فاتبعناه
بعضا وجعلناهم احاديث فبعدا لقوم لا
يؤمنون ثم ارسلنا موسى واخاه هارون
باياتنا وسلطان
مبين الى فرعون وملاه فاستكبروا وكانوا
قوما عالين فقالوا انؤمن لبشرين مثلنا
وقومهما لنا
عابدون فكذبوهما فكانوا من
المهلكين ولقد اتينا موسى الكتاب لعلهم
يهتدون وجعلنا ابن مريم
وامه ايه واويناهما الى ربوه ذات قرار
ومعين يا ايها الرسل كلوا من الطيبات
واعملوا
صالحا اني بما تعملون
عليم وان هذه امتكم
امه واحده وانا ربكم
فاتقون الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن حمده
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر بسم
الله الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين وان هذه امتكم امه واحده وانا ربكم
فاتقون فتقطعوا امرهم بينهم زبرا كل حزب
بما لديهم فرحوا
فذرهم في غمرتهم حتى حين ايحسبون انما
نمدهم به من مال
وبنين نسارع لهم في الخيرات بلا يشعرون ان
الذين هم من خشيه ربهم
مشفقون والذين هم بايات ربهم يؤمنون
والذين هم بربهم لا يشركون
الذين يؤتون ما اتوا وقلوبهم
وجله وقلوبهم وجله انهم الى ربهم
راجعون اولئك يسارعون في الخيرات وهم لها
سابقون ولا نكلف نفسا الا وسعها ولدينا
كتاب ينطق بالحق وهم لا
يظلمون حتى اذا اخذنا حتى اذا اخذنا
مت بل قلوبهم في غمره من هذا ولهم اعمال
من دون ذلك هم لها
عاملون حتى اذا اخذنا متر فيهم بالعذاب
اذا هم
يجارون لا تجوا اليوم انكم منا لا
تنصرون قد كانت ايه التي تتلى عليكم فكنتم
على اعقابكم
تنكصون مستكبرين به سامرا
تهجرون افلم يدبروا القول ام جاءهم ما لم
يات
اباءهم
الاولين ام لم يعرفوا رسولهم فهم له
منكرون ام يقولون به جنه بل جاءهم
بالحق واكثرهم للحق
كارهون ولو اتبع الحق
اهواءهم لفسدت السماوات والارض ومن
فيهن بل اتيناهم بذكرهم فهم عن ذكرهم
معرضون ام تسالهم خرجا فخراج ربك خير وهو
خير الرازقين
وانك لتدعوهم الى صراط
مستقيم وان الذين لا يؤمنون بالاخره عن
الصراط لناكبون
ولو رحمناهم وكشفنا ما بهم من ضر للجوا في
طغيانهم
يعمهون ولقد اخذناهم بالعذاب فما استكانوا
لربهم وما يتضرعون
حتى اذا فتحنا عليهم بابا ذا عذاب شديد
اذا هم فيه مبلسون
وهو الذي انشا لكم السمع والابصار
والافئده قليلا ما تشكرون وهو الذي ذراكم
في الارض واليه
تحشرون وهو الذي يحيي ويميت وله اخت خلاف
الليل
والنهار افلا
تعقلون الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله رحمت الله
[Silence]
الله اكبر
بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين وهو الذي يحيي ويميت وله اختلاف
الليل والنهار افلا
تعقلون بل قالوا مثلما قال
الاولون قالوا ائذا متنا وكنا ترابا
وعظاما اانا لمبعوث
ثون لقد وعدنا نحن
واباؤنا هذا من قبل ان هذا الا اساطير
الاولين قل لمن الارض ومن فيها ان كنتم
تعلمون سيقولون لله قل افلا
تذكرون قل من رب السماوات السبع ورب العرش
العظيم سيقولون لله قل افلا
تتقون قل من بيده ملكوت كل شيء وهو يجير
ولا يجار عليه ان كنتم
تعلمون سيقولون لله قل فانا
تسحرون بل اتيناهم بالحق وانهم
لكاذبون ما اتخذ الله من ولد وما كان معه
من اله اذا لذهب كل اله بما خلق ول على
بعضهم على بعض سبحانه وتعالى عما
يصفون سبحان الله عما
يصفون عالم الغيب والشهاده فتعالى عما
يشركون قل رب اما ترين
ما يوعدون رب فلا تجعلني في القوم
الظالمين وانا على ان نري كما نعدهم
لقادرون ادفع بالتي هي احسن السيئه نحن
اعلم بما
يصفون وقل رب اعوذ بك من همزات
الشياطين واعوذ بك رب ان
يحضرون حتى اذا جاء احدهم الموت قال ربي
ارجعون لعلي اعمل صالحا فيما تركت كلا
انها كلمه هو
قائلها ومن
ورائهم برزخ الى يوم
يبعثون فاذا نفخ في الصور فلا انساب بينهم
يومئذ ولا
يتساءلون فمن ثقلت موازينه فاولئك هم
المفلحون ومن خفت موازينه فاولئك الذين
خسروا انفسهم في جهنم
خالدون تلفح وجوههم النار وهم فيها
كالحون الم تكن اياتي تتلى عليكم فكنتم
بها
تكذبون قالوا ربنا غلبت علينا شقوتنا وكنا
قوما
ضالين ربنا اخرجنا منها فان عدنا فانا
ظالمون قال اخسؤوا فيها ولا
تكلمون انه كان فريق من عبادي يقولون ربنا
امنا فاغفر لنا وارحمنا وانت خير
الراحمين فاتخذتموهم
سخريا حتى انسوكم ذكري
وكنتم منهم
تضحكون اني جزيتهم اليوم بما صبروا انهم
هم الفائزون
قال كم لبثتم في الارض عدد سنين قالوا
لبثنا يوما او بعض يوم فاسال
العادين قال ان لبثتم الا قليلا لو انكم
كنتم
تعلمون افحسبتم انما خلقناكم عبثا وانكم
الينا لا
ترجعون فتعالى الله
الملك
الحق لا اله الا هو رب العرش
الكريم ومن يدع مع الله الها اخر لا برهان
له به فانما حسابه عند
ربه انه لا يفلح
الكافرون وقل رب اغفر وارحم وانت خير
الراحمين
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر الله
[Silence]
اكبر بسم الله الحمد لله رب الع العالمين
الرحمن الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد
واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين بسم الله الرحم
سوره انزلناها وفرضناها وانزلنا فيها ايات
بينات لعلكم
تذكرون الزانيه والزاني فاجلدوا كل واحد
منهما مئه جله ولا تاخذكم بهما رافه في
دين
الله ولا تاخذكم بهما رافه في دين الله ان
كنتم مؤمنون بالله واليوم الاخر وليشهد
عذابهما
طائفه من
المؤمنين الزاني لا ينكح الا زانيه او
مشركه والزانيه لا ينكحها الا زان او مشرك
وحرم ذلك على
المؤمنين و حرم ذلك على المؤمنين والذين
يرمون المحصنات ثم لم ياتوا باربعه شهداء
فاجلدوهم ثمين جلده ولا تقبلوا منهم شهاده
ابدا واولئك هم
الفاسقون الا الذين تابوا من بعد ذلك
واصلحوا فان الله غفور
رحيم والذي يرمون ازواجهم ولم يكن لهم
شهداء الا انفسهم فشها
احدهم فشها احدهم اربع شهادات بالله انه
لمن
الصادقين والخامسه ان لعنه الله عليه ان
كان من
الكاذبين ويدرا عنها العذاب ان تشهد اربع
شهادات بالله انه لمن
الكاذبين والخامسه ان غضب الله عليها ان
كان من
الصادقين ولولا فضل الله عليكم ورحمته وان
الله تواب
حكيم ان الذين جاءوا بالافك عصبه منكم لا
تحسبوه شرا لك
بل هو خير لكم لكل امرئ منهم ما اكتسب من
الاثم والذي تولى كبره منهم له عذاب
عظيم لولا اذ سمعتموه ظن المؤمنون
والمؤمنات
بانفسهم خيرا وقالوا هذا افك
مبين لولا اذ جاءوا عليه باربعه شهداء
لولا جاءوا عليه باربعه
شهداء فاذ لم ياتوا
بالشهداء فاولئك عند الله هم
الكاذبون ولولا فضل الله عليكم ورحمته في
الدنيا والاخره
لمسكم لمسكم فيما افضتم فيه عذاب عظيم
اذ تلقونه بالسنتكم وتقولون بافواهكم ما
ليس لكم به علم وتحسبونه هينا وهو عند
الله
عظيم ولولا اذ سمعتموه قلتم ما يكون لنا
ان نتكلم بهذا سبحانك هذا بهتان
عظيم يعظكم الله ان تعودوا لمثله ابدا ان
كنتم
مؤمنين ويبين الله لكم الايات والله عليم
حكيم ان الذين يحبون ان تشيع الفاحشه في
الذين امنوا لهم عذاب اليم في الدنيا
والاخره والله يعلم وانتم لا تعلمون
ولولا فضل الله عليكم ورحمته وان الله
رؤوف
رحيم
الله سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله
[Silence]
بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم والصلاه والسلام على رسول الله و
اله وصحبه ووه ومن تعب باحسان الى يوم
الدين اما بعد
[Silence]
‏make
as سبهالى
رب اني مسني ض وانم
الرامين
دعا as
[Silence]
‏because عليه
واللام me we know the
isic
time so
one
شيان سبحانه وتالى
[Silence]
عليه was very
well field and house
عليه
[Silence]
الله
every ل
‏cance ks and and him dis on
body and i will just mention it because
some have gone as far as mentioning what
the condition was for his body and some
of them are just exaggerated account so
in will not mention those but i'll just
mention that he had open sour all over
his body and it was so bad of that there
mags that actually in his ws now لا الله
[Silence]
‏not
عل
[Silence]
‏cle
say
one i that
[Silence]
‏his j is to out of the isam why said
that's i made the statement god for we
are afflicted
any
be canb
[Silence]
عليه
اني مسني
‏small all
things
house people us
toite comm us my
wife
‏just وان ارحم
الرام are the
mer
اللهانه فاستجبنا له وكشفنا من الظر وينا
واتيناه اهله ومثله معه رحمه من عندنا
وذكريا الله
اللهب عليه
[Silence]
‏beauful
as so so when the wife enter house are
out my house
mar
me
re grs
[Silence]
‏where lally little creatures you know i
mean and ay is grabing them and
extends you know he op shirt and he gra
it in his you know
kind little he makes out
of know call english i don't know i
don't think english word for it don't
know
الله bl
اللهد
رحمه ي مسني ضم
الرحمين
time we
‏right so الله be mindful and some ises
in life and we all do who one of us can
claim that we don't have ises in lives
we all have it all of our battles are
different your is might be different my
is but we still have ises and that's
part of human
life this is this is not the
ي مسني ض وتم
[Silence]
الرامين الله
‏ask from as are
not
as sins are for over and over again i
knowed
[Silence]
الحد ‏to remove our
next
make exit
from
ليه الله سبانت
‏was
[Silence]
ال الا الله محمد
رسول ربنا اتنا في النيا حسنه وفي الاخره
حسنه وقنا عذاب النار وقنا عذاب القبر
وقنا عذاب جهنم وقناته المح الممات وكنا
فتنه المسيح الدجال ربنا تقبل منا انك
السميع العليم وتوب علنا الرحيم صلى الله
على محد وعلى اله وصحه اجمعين الرام اللهم
امين اللهم اللهم ام
[Silence]
استقيم واعتدل استو سو الصف سد
الخلل الله اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين يا ايها الذين امنوا لا تتخذوا لا
تتبعوا خطوات
الشيطان ومن يتبع خطوات الشيطان فانه يامر
بالفحشاء
والمنكر ولولا فضل الله عليكم ورحمته ما
زكى منكم من احد
ابدا ولكن الله يزكي من يشاء والله سميع
عليم ولا ياتل اولو الفضل منكم والسعه ان
يؤتوا اولي القربى والمساكين
والمهاجرين في سبيل الله
وليعفوا
وليصفحوا الا تحبون ان يغفر الله لكم
والله غفور رحيم ان الذين يرمون المحصنات
الغافلات المؤمنات لعنوا في الدنيا
والاخره لعنوا في الدنيا والاخره ولهم
عذاب عظيم يوم تشهد عليهم السنتهم وايديهم
وارجلهم بما كانوا
يعملون يومئذ يوفيهم الله دينهم
الحق ويعلمون ان الله هو الحق المبين
الخبيثات
للخبيثين
والخبيثون
للخبيثات
والطيبات للط الطيبين
والطيبون
للطيبات
اولئك مبرؤون
مما
يقولون لهم
مغفره
ورزق كريم يا ايها الذين امنوا لا تدخلوا
بيوتا حتى تستانسوا وتسلموا على اهلها
يا يا ايها الذين امنوا لا تدخلوا بيوتا
غير بيوتكم حتى تستانسوا وتسلموا على
اهلها ذلكم خير لكم لعلكم
تذكرون فان لم تجدوا فيها احدا فلا تدخلوا
فيها حتى يؤذن لكم
وان قيل لكم ارجعوا
فارجعوا فان لم تجدوا فيها احدا فلا
تدخلوها حتى يؤذن لكم وان قيل لكم ارجعوا
فارجعوا هو خير لكم هو ازكى لكم والله
يعلم ما تعمل والله عليم بما
تعملون والله بما تعملون عليم ليس عليكم
جناح ان تدخلوا بيوتا غير
مسكونه فيها متاع
لكم ليس عليكم جناح ان تدخلوا بيوتا بيوتا
غير
مسكونه فيها متاع لكم
والله يعلم ما تبدون وما
تكتمون قل
للمؤمنين يغضوا من ابصارهم ويحفظوا
فروجهم ذلك خ ذلك ازكى لهم ذلك ازكى لهم
ان الله خبير بما
يصنعون وقل للم المؤمنات يغضضن من
ابصارهن ويحفظن
فروجهن ولا يبدين
زينتهن الا ما ظهر
منها وليضربن
بخمرهن على
جيوبهن ولا يبدين
زينتهن الا لبعولتهن او اباء
هن او
ابائهن او
اباء بعولتهن او
ابنائهن او
ابناء بعولتهن
او
اخوانهن او بني
اخواتهن او
نسائهن او ما ملكت
ايمانهن او التابعين غير اولي الاربه من
الرجال او الطفل الذين لم يبل لم
يظهروا او الطفل الذين لم يظهر على عورات
النساء ولا ضربن بارجلهن
ليعلم ما يخفين من
زينتهن وتوبوا الى الله جميعا ايها
المؤمنون وتوبوا الى الله جميعا ايها
المؤمنون لعلكم
تفلحون وانكحوا الاياما منكم
والصالحين من عبادكم
واماء ان يكونوا
فقراء يغنيهم الله من فضله والله واسع
عليم
وليستعفف الذين لا يجدون نكاحا حتى يغنيهم
الله من فضله والذين يبتغون الكتاب مما
ملكت ايمانكم فكاتبوهم
فكاتبوهم ان علمتم فيهم خيرا
واتوهم من مال الله الذي
اتاكم ولا تكرهوا فتياتكم على
البغاء ان اردن
تحصنا ان اردن تحصنا لتبتغوا عرضا الحياه
الدنيا ومن
يكرههن فان الله من بعد
اكراههن غفور
رحيم ولقد
انزلنا اليكم ايات
مبينات
ومثلا
ومث من الذين خلوا من
قبلكم
وموعظه
للمتقين الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين الله نور السماوات
والارض مثل نوره
كمشكاه فيها
مصباح المصباح في
زجاجه الزجاجه
كانها كوكب دري يوقد من شجره
مباركه زيتونه لا
شرقيه ولا غربيه
يكاد زيتها
يضيء ولو لم تمسسه نار نور على
نور يهدي الله لنوره من
يشاء ويضرب الله الامثال للناس والله بكل
شيء عليم في بيوت اذن الله ان ترفع ويذكر
فيها اسمه يسبح له فيها بالغدو والاصال
رجال رجال لا تلهيهم تجاره ولا بيع عن ذكر
الله واقام الصلاه
وايتاء
الزكاه يخافون يوما تتقلب فيه القلوب
والابصار
ليجزيهم الله احسن ما عملوا
ويزيدهم من
فضله والله يرزق من يشاء بغير
حساب والذين كفروا ا اعمالهم كسراب بقيعه
يحسبه الظمان
ماءه حتى اذا جاءه لم يجده شيئا ووجد الله
عنده فوفاه
حسابه والله سريع
الحساب او كظلمات في بحر لجي يغشاه موج من
فوقه موج من فوقه
سحاب
ظلمات بعضها فوق
بعض اذا اخرج يده لم يكد
يراها ومن لم يجعل الله له نورا فما له من
نور الم تر ان الله يسبح له من في
السماوات
والارض والطير
صافات كل قد علم صلاته
وتسبيحه والله عليم
ما
يفعلون الم تعلم الا ان وان لله ملك
السماوات
والارض ولله ملك السماوات والارض واليه
المصير الم ترى
واليه واليه
المصير ولله ملك السماوات والارض والى
الله الم ير الم تر ان الله يزجي سحابا ثم
يؤلف بينه ثم يجعله
ركاما فترى الودق يخرج من
خلاله وينزل من
السماء من جبال فيها من برد فيصيب به من
يشاء ويصر
عمن
يشاء يكاد سنا برقه يذهب
بالابصار يقلب الله الليل
والنهار ان في ذلك لعبره لاولي
الابصار والله خلق كل
دابه مما
فمنهم من يمشي على بطنه
ومنهم
ومنهم من يمشي على رجلين ومنهم من يمشي
على اربع يخلق الله ما
يشاء والله على كل
شيء
قدير ان الله على كل شيء
قدير لقد
انزلنا ايات مبي لقد انزلنا اليكم ايات
مبينات ولقد لقد
انزلنا ايات
مبينات والله يهدي من يشاء الى صراط
مستقيم ويقول قولون امنا بالله وبالرسول
واطعنا ثم يتولى فريق منهم من بعد ذلك وما
اولئك
بالمؤمنين واذا دعوا الى الله ليحكم بينهم
اذا فريق منهم
معرضون وان يكن لهم الحق ياتوا اليه
مذعنين واذا دعوا الى الله ورسوله ليحكم
بينهم اذا فريق اذا فريق منهم
معرضون وان يكن لهم الحق ياتوا اليه
مذعنين افي قلوبهم مرض ام
ارتابوا ام يخاف
ان يحيف الله عليهم
ورسوله بل
اولئك هم
الظالمون انما كان قول المؤمنين اذا ادعوا
الى الله ورسوله ليحكم بينهم ان يقولوا
سمعنا
واطعنا
واولئك هم المفلحون
ومن يطع الله ورسوله ويخشى
الله ويخشى الله ويتقيه
فاولئك هم
الفائزون الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
استقيموا
اعتدلوا الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين واقسموا بالله جهد ايمانهم لئن
امرتهم
ليخرجن قل لا تقسموا طاعه معروفه ان الله
خبير بما تعملون قل اطيعوا الله
والرسول قل اطيعوا الله واطيعوا الرسول
فان تولوا
فانما عليه ما حمل وعليكم ما
حملتم
وان وان تطيعوه
تهتدوا وما على الرسول الا البلاغ
المبين وعد الله الذين امنوا منكم وعملوا
الصالحات ليستخلفنهم في الارض ليستخلفنهم
في الارض وليمكنن
لهم دينهم الذي ارتضى
لهم ليستخلفنهم في الارض كما استخلف الذين
من قبلهم وليمكنن
ان لهم دينهم الذي ارتضى لهم وليبدلنهم
من بعد خوفهم
امنا
يعبدونني لا يشركون بي شيئا ومن كفر بعد
ذلك
فاولئك هم
الفاسقون واقيموا الصلاه واتوا الزكاه
واطيعوا الرسول
واطيعوا الرسول لعلكم
ترحمون لا
تحسبن الذين كفروا
معجزين وماواهم النار ولبئس
المصير لا تحسبن الذين كفروا معجزين في
الارض وماواهم النار ولبئس المصير
يا ايها الذين امنوا ليستاذنكم
الذين ملكت ايمانكم والذين لم يبلغوا
الحلم والذين لم يبلغوا الحلم منكم ثلاث
مرات ثلاث مرات من بعد صلاه الفجر وحين
تضعون ثيابكم من
الظهيره من قبل صلاه الفجر وحين تضعون
ثيابكم وحين تضعون ثيابكم من الظهيره ومن
بعد صلاه العشاء ثلاث عورات لكم ليس عليكم
ولا عليهم جناح بعدهن طوافون عليكم طوافون
عليكم بعضكم على
بعض كذلك يبين الله لكم الايات والله عليم
حكيم واذا بلغ الاطفال منكم الحلم فليستا
هذن فليستا هذن كما استاذن الذين من
قبلهم كذلك يبين الله لكم اياته والله
عليم حكيم والقواعد من النساء
اللاتي لا يرجون نكاحا فليس عليهن جناح ان
يضعن ثيابهن غير
متبرجات بزينه وان يستعففن خير لهم والله
سميع
عليم وان يستعففن خير لهن والله سميع
ليس على الاعمى حرج ولا على الاعرج حرج
ولا على المريض حرج ولا على المريض حرج
ولا على
انفسكم ان تاكلوا من
بيوتكم ان تاكلوا من بيوتكم او بيوت
ابائكم او بيوت
امهاتكم او بيوت اخوانكم او بيوت اخواتكم
او بيوت اعمامكم او بيوت
عماتكم او بيوت
عماتكم او بيوت اخوالكم او بيوت
خالاتكم او ما ملكتم مفاتحه او
صديقكم ليس عليكم جناح ان تاكلوا جميعا او
اشتاتا
فاذا
دخلتم بيوتا فسلموا على
انفسكم فسلموا على انفسكم
تحيه من عند الله
مباركه
طيبه كذلك يبين الله لكم الايات لعلكم
تعقلون انما المؤمنون الذين امنوا بالله
ورسوله واذا كانوا واذا كانوا معه على امر
جامع لم يذهبوا حتى
يستاذنه ان الذين
يستاذنك اولئك الذين يؤمنون بالله
ورسوله فان فان استاذنك لبعض شانهم فاذن
لمن شئت منهم واستغفر لهم الله ان فاذا
استاذنك لبعض شانهم فاذن لمن شئت
منهم واستغفر لهم الله ان الله غفور رحيم
لا تجعلوا
دعاء الرسول بينكم كدعاء بعضكم بعضا قد
يعلم الله الذين يتسللون من م
لواذا قد يعلم الله الذين يتسللون منكم
لواذا فليحذر الذين يخالفون عن امره ان
تصيبهم فتنه او يصيبهم عذاب اليم الا
ان لله ما في السماوات والارض قد يعلم ما
انتم
عليه ويوم يرجعون اليه
فينبئهم بما
عملوا ان الله بكل شيء
عليم الله
اكبر سمع الله الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين الا ان لله ما في السماوات والارض
يعلم قد يعلم ما انتم
عليه ويوم يرجعون يرجعون اليه
فينبئهم بما عملوا والله بكل شيء
عليم تبارك الذي نزل الفرقان على عبده
ليكون للعالمين نذيرا الذي له ملك
السماوات والارض ولم يتخذ ولدا ولم يكن له
شريك في الملك وخلق كل شيء فقدره تقديرا
واتخذوا من دونه الهه لا يخلقون شيئا ولا
يخلقون ولا يملكون
لانفسهم ضرا ولا نفعا ولا يملكون موتا ولا
حياه ولا
نشورا واتخذوا من دون الله الهه لا يخلق
لا يخلقون شيئا وهم
يخلقون ولا ولا يملكون
لانفسهم ضرا ولا نفعا ولا يملكون موتا ولا
حياه ولا
نشورا وقال الذين كفروا ان هذا الا افك
افتراه واعانه عليه قوم
اخرون فقد جاء
ظلما
وزورا وقالوا اساطير الاولين
اكتتبها فهي تملى عليه بكره
واصيلا قل انزله الذي يعلم السر في
السماوات والارض انه كان غفورا
رحيما وقالوا ما لهذا الرسول ياكل الطعام
ويمشي في
الاسواق لولا انزل اليه ملك فيكون معه
نذيرا او يلقى اليه كنز او تكون له جنه
ياكل
منها وقال الظالمون ان تتبعون الا رجلا
مسحورا انظر كيف ضربوا لك كامثال
فضلوا فضلوا فلا يستطيعون
سبيلا تبارك الذي ان شاء جعل لك خيرا من
ذلك
جنات
جنات تجري من تحتها الانهار ويجعل لك
قصورا بل كذبوا بالساعه واعتدنا لمن كذب
بالساعه
سعيرا اذا راتهم من مكان قريب سمعوا لها
تغيظا
وزفيرا اذا راتهم من مكان بعيد سمعوا لها
وزفيرا واذا القوا فيها مكانا ضيقا
قرنين دعوا هنالك
ثبورا لا تدعوا اليوم ثبورا واحدا وادعوا
ثبورا
كب
كبيرا وادعوا ثبورا كثيرا قل اذلك خير ام
جنه الخلد التي وعد
المتقون كانت لهم
جزاء و
صيرا لهم فيها ما
يشاؤون
خالدين كان على ربك وعدا
مسؤولا ويوم يحشرهم وما يعبدون من دون
الله
فيقول فيقول انتم اضللتم عبادي
هؤلاء ام هم ضلوا السبيل قالوا قالوا
سبحانك ما كان ينبغي ان نتخذ من دونك من
اولياء قالوا سبحانك ما كان ينبغي لنا ان
نتخذ من دونك من
اولياء ولكن متعتهم
واباءهم حتى نسوا حتى نسوا الذكر وكانوا
قوما بورا فقد كذبوكم بما تقولون فما
تستطيعون صرفا ولا
نصرا ومن يظلم منكم نذقه عذابا كبيرا وما
ارسلنا من قبلك من المرسلين الا انهم الا
انهم لياكلون طعام ويمشون في
الاسواق وجعلنا بعضكم لبعض فتنه
اتصبرون وكان ربك
ظهيرا الله
اكبر سمع الله
لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
شاف الوتر
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين سبح اسم ربك الاعلى الذي خلق فسوى
والذي قدر فهدى والذي اخرج المرعى فجعله
غثاء احوى
سنقرئك فلا تنسى الا ما شاء
الله انه يعلم الجهر وما
يخفى ونيسرك لليسرى فذكر ان نفعت
الذكرى سيذكر من يخشى
ويتجنبها الاشقى الذي يصلى النار
الكبرى ثم لا يموت فيها ولا
يحيا قد افلح من تزكى وذكر اسم ربه
فصلى بل تؤثرون الحياه الدنيا والاخره
خير
وابقى ان هذا لفي الصحف
الاولى صحف ابراهيم
وموسى الله
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضالين
امين قل يا ايها
الكافرون لا اعبد ما
تعبدون ولا انتم عابدون ما
اعبد ولا انا عابد ما
عبدتم ولا انتم عابدون ما اعبد لكم دينكم
ولي
دين الله
الله سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه
الله الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالم العالمين الرحمن
الرحيم مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين قل هو الله احد
الله الصمد لم يلد ولم
يولد ولم يكن له كفوا
احد الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده ربنا ولك الحمد حمدا كثيرا طيبا
مباركا فيه ملء السماوات وملء الارض وملء
ما بينهما وملء ما شئت من شيء بعد اهل
الثناء والمجد احق ما قال العبد وكلنا لك
عبد اللهم لا مانع لما اعطيت ولا معطي لما
منعت ولا ينفع ذا الجد منك
الجد اللهم اهدنا في من هديت وعافنا في من
عافيت وتولنا في منن توليت وبارك اللهم
لنا فيما اعطيت وقنا واصرف عنا برحمتك شر
ما قضيت انك سبحانك تقضي بالحق ولا يقضى
عليك انه لا يذل من واليت ولا يعز من
عاديت تباركت ربنا
وتعاليت اللهم اللهم احسن عاقبتنا في
الامور كلها اجرنا من خزي الدنيا وعذاب
الاخره اللهم انا نسالك عيشه سويه اللهم
انا نسالك عيشه هنيه وميته سويه ومردا غير
مخز ولا فاضح برحمتك يا ارحم الراحمين
اللهم اقسم لنا من خشيتك ما تحول به بيننا
وبين معصيتك ومن طاعتك ما تبلغنا به جنتك
ومن اليقين ما تهون به علينا مصائب الدنيا
اللهم متعنا باسماعنا وابصارنا
وقواتنا ابدا ما ابقيت واجعله الوارث
منا واجعل ثارنا على من ظلمنا وانصرنا على
من عادانا ولا تجعل مصيبتنا في ديننا ولا
تجعل الدنيا اكبر همنا ولا مبلغ المنا ولا
تجعل الى النار مصيرنا واجعل الجنه هي
دارنا
وقرارنا برحمتك يا ارحم
الراحمين اللهم انصر المسلمين المستضعفين
في كل مكان اللهم كن لهم ولا تكن
عليهم اللهم انصر اخواننا المجاهدين في كل
مكان اللهم انصر اخواننا المجاهدين في غزه
اللهم اطعم جائعهم
وا واسق ضمانهم واكس عاريهم وفك قيد
اسيرم وسدد رمي مجاهد ايهم برحمتك يا ارحم
الراحمين اللهم كن لهم وانصرهم واخذل
عدوهم واجعل كيدهم في نحورهم واجعل
الدائره تدور
عليهم بفضلك وقوتك يا رب العالمين
اللهم اعتق رقابنا من النار اللهم اعتق
رقابنا من النار اللهم اعتق رقابنا من
النار برحمتك يا عزيز يا غفار سبحان ربك
رب العزه عما يصفون وسلام على المرسلين
والحمد لله رب العالمين وصل اللهم وسلم
على سيدنا محمد وعلى اله وصحبه اجمعين
الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام
عليكم ورحمه الله